BURT HERMANN: Thank you very
much for coming here tonight.
I definitely want to thank
Google for being such gracious
hosts and having us here.
Yes, definitely applause
for them.
With the beautiful view, which
is hopefully not too
distracting.
My name is Burt, I'm the
organizer of Hacks and
Hackers, and I know we have
perhaps a lot of new faces
here tonight, so I thought I
would just explain a little
bit about what that is.
Hacks and Hackers is a group
for journalists and
technologists.
So hacks, a hack is actually a
slang term for a journalist,
hackers obviously slang term for
a developer, and the idea
really is to bring these two
groups together to think about
the future of media.
We're living through this
amazing time of revolution--
What?
[AUDIENCE MURMUR AND LAUGHTER]
Oh, music.
"Ladada." Yes, that was
planned, that's all--
[LAUGHS]
So, we're living through this
time of media revolution, and
really everything is changing.
Obviously that's why
you're all here.
I mean, the way they you create
media is bound up with
technology.
The way people are telling
stories is bound together with
technology.
There's amazing tools
out there.
People are empowered
like never before.
And Hacks and Hackers is about
trying to encourage new ways
of thinking about this.
Trying to get people to actually
create things.
We do Hackathons, we have
training workshops, and it
started as just kind of
a meet-up group in San
Francisco, and we've grown
since then to actually an
international organization, and
now we have chapters all
over the world.
We have nearly 2,000 people in
New York, in a group there.
We have active groups
in Argentina.
We have somebody setting these
groups up across Africa.
So really it's become part of
this movement because I think
there is such a hunger out
there to figure out where
things are going.
This is important because we
need to be informed about
society, we need to make
sure government is held
accountable, that doesn't
change with the media.
But how can we take the
best of the old and
combine it with the new?
That's really what this
is all about.
So, with that, I'm going
to introduce--
Jarek from YouTube is going to
talk about the event, and he's
going to run this, and
introduce some of the
company's that'll
be presenting.
And we're actually gonna save
all the questions for the end,
which I'll say now and he will
say again, and have a lot of
time where people can
be interactive then.
So please hold your questions
to the end.
Thanks.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Good
evening, everybody.
Before we start, I would like
to give a hand to our VC
Operations.
So there's people in space who
are recording this event right
now, and hopefully you'll be
able to see this online a
little later.
So we just went through
the introductions.
Before proceeding, I
just wanted to call
out a couple of names.
I have Olivia Ma here with
me from YouTube News
and Politics team.
She did a lot of work
on this event.
And Hannah Eaves from Link TV.
Link TV is sponsoring alcohol
tonight, so this is the most
important part of the event.
[LAUGHTER]
So here's the agenda
for tonight.
We're going to go through the
API Overview, so I get my five
minutes of fame.
And then we'll have Lightning
talks from YouTube, and
Storyful, Storefy, ShortForm,
and Link TV. And we'll try to
keep it on track, five
minutes each.
At the end we'll have a Q&A
session, and hopefully fun.
Please leave us feedback at
the end of the session.
I have set up a short link
and the QR code.
We'll show it again during
the Q&A session.
We would really appreciate
your feedback.
And if you would like to tweet
about this event, here's the
hashtag: #hackshackers.
All right, so enough
logistics.
I would like to start
with a quiz.
Actually, I need to
start [INAUDIBLE]
since I get five minutes.
All right, so how much you
know about YouTube?
First question is, how
many YouTube views
do we get per day?
2, 3, 5 zillion?
2 million?
Come on, guys, I have
only five minutes.
100 million?
2 billion?
5 billion?
It's actually over
3 billion now.
So you were pretty close.
Next one.
Out of these views, how
many are mobile?
10 million, 20 million,
30 million?
[AUDIENCE MURMUR]
10?
100 million?
AUDIENCE: 500 million.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: 500 million?
Actually, it's over 200
million, and this is
data from last year.
How much video is uploaded
each minute?
That should be simple.
think a lot of--
[AUDIENCE MURMUR]
How many?
AUDIENCE: 48 hours?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: 48?
35?
It's actually over 48,
so you were right on.
And last question.
How much viewership does
YouTube get from
outside of the US?
So the percentage views coming
in from outside of US?
AUDIENCE: 50%.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: 50, 60, 70.
AUDIENCE: 70.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Right
on, 70's the number.
All right, so now let's
talk about APIs.
So we have two sets of APIs.
Google Data APIs and
player APIs.
So first of all, how many of you
have actually used YouTube
APIs before?
Fair amount.
And how many have use
any Google APIs?
OK, great.
So this should be pretty
straightforward.
So when you think about the APIs
that YouTube offers, we
have the back in APIs.
So you saw the APIs you use to
interact with, for example,
our search engine, to interact
with the video rating
capability, comments,
and so forth.
The player APIs let you
customize the player behavior.
So if you're building a website
or web application and
you care about user experience,
and you really
want to get the most out of the
video playback capability,
you can use the player
APIs to customize it.
Google Data APIs are based on
rest. So if you know rest,
that needs no further
explanations.
If you don't, all it really
means is that you can access
the API back end over HTTP in
a very straightforward way,
and I'll demonstrate how you can
do that in the next slide.
We support a couple of
encoding formats.
ATOM, JSON, JSON-C, for those
of you that are Javascript
programmers and you
really like JSON.
And we have a set of open source
libraries that allow
you to access to YouTube back
end using your favorite
programming language.
So you would rather write Java
code and you don't have to
deal with XML and JSON
and all that, we do
have support for that.
We have C# libraries,
Objective-C libraries, we have
PHP libraries, we have pretty
much libraries for most of the
major programming languages.
And the way we organize the data
is we talk about feeds,
so anything on YouTube is
represented as a feed.
So if you would like to
know, what are the
top videos on YouTube?
Or what are the most viewed
videos on YouTube?
Or what are the subscriptions?
What you get back is an XML
document, or JSON document
that consists of an outer entity
called "feed" and the
inner entities called "entries."
And YouTube API
applications interact with the
YouTube platform using the
Google Data APIs.
I have an example
here of a feed.
This feed represents top-rated
videos on YouTube.
And in order to access its feed,
all I need to do is just
click this URL issue an HTTP
get request, and what I get
back is a bunch of XML entries
corresponding to the videos
that are top-rated on YouTube.
As you see, each video
has a video ID.
It's very straight forward.
So really what I just did is I
used the YouTube API in order
to get information about
top-rated YouTube videos.
Player APIs.
There are three ways in which
you can actually interact with
the player.
The simplest one is through the
URI parameters, and then
we have JavaScript API and
ActionScript APIs for those of
you that really would like to
get fancy with customization
of the player.
So player parameters, the
easiest way to interact with
the player behavior.
Here are two examples.
The first one is the
old object embed.
And in this example, I'm
actually telling the object in
the bed-- which represents a
video, a YouTube video--
to not allow the user to play
the video on full screen.
So I want to take entire
control over the user
experience.
I don't want them to
ever leave my site.
I just want them to see the
video embedded on my site.
I can do that by appending an FS
equals zero parameter to my
embed code.
And then similarly, using the
new iFrame embed codes--
this is something that we've
been promoting lately--
you can actually trigger the
video to start playing as soon
as somebody navigates to a page
which has this embed, and
the autoplay parameter
does this.
So here's an example for those
of you that would really like
to control the player
behavior a lot more.
You can use JavaScript
for that.
And in this example I actually
tell the player to play a
video for 10 seconds
and then stop.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ELEPHANT: Hey zebra, how do I
make a cool YouTube video?
ZEBRA: Go to youtube.com/create
and type--
[END PLAYBACK VIDEO]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
So what you see is I was able
to tell the player to--
and there's my timer--
to start the playback and then
stop it after 10 seconds.
And my time is up.
So I have a couple of other cool
things to discuss, so if
you'd like to learn more
about the API, see
me after the show.
Thank you.
Now we going to have Olivia
talk about YouTube Direct.
OLIVIA MA: Hi everyone.
My name's Olivia Ma, and I'm the
YouTube news manager, and
today I want to talk really
briefly about an application
that we built and released about
a year and a half ago
called YouTube Direct, which is
an open source application
using the YouTube API.
So a little background on why
we created this tool.
In today's world, there are so
many mobile phones that are
video-enabled, and you have
such widespread broadband
access that we believe that
everyone can be a reporter.
Now, before anybody comes at me,
that does not mean that we
believe that everyone could be a
journalist. In fact, we very
strongly believe that the role
of the journalist has never
been more important.
But the fact that now anybody
can document the news and
events happening around them,
can bear witness to news that
is unfolding before their
eyes, has fundamentally
changed, I think, the way
that we gather news.
And I think everyone
can agree to that.
A few examples.
Obviously most recently, what's
been happening in the
Middle East, the Arab Spring,
we've been seeing every single
one of these countries that is
undergoing political change,
we're seeing this play
out on YouTube.
Egypt, Tunisia, Libya, Algeria,
Yemen, and Syria
right now, we're seeing a lot
of footage out there.
It's pretty incredible, and this
has become indispensable
to a lot of news
organizations.
A local example that I think
we're all familiar with was
the Oscar Grant shooting.
And I think this is particularly
relevant this
week since there have been a
number of other SFPD-related
incidents that have been
captured on video.
This was an example where many
people saw a young man be shot
in the BART station and captured
it on video from
multiple angles.
And these became really
important videos in that case.
And then I think a lighter
example, but an example of
sort of how commentary can
play in on YouTube, when
Michael Jackson died, we saw
in just a huge influx of
response videos about what
that death meant to
individuals, to our culture.
And so you can see that it's not
just news events but also
commentary and conversation
around the news.
So what we wanted to do was
create essentially a virtual
assignment desk.
An application that would allow
news organizations to
embed the YouTube upload
functionality on their site.
So we decided to create YouTube
Direct, which I
mentioned is open source, and
it allows news organizations
or really any news, any website,
to easily integrate
an audience engagement platform
on their site.
There are two pieces to this
and I'll talk about that a
little bit more detail
on the next slide.
But basically, you have an
embeddable uploading tool, and
then you have an admin interface
that allows your
editors, or the keepers of your
site, to actually manage
the submissions.
So quick overview of
the technology.
YouTube Direct is built using
the YouTube API and it's built
on top of Google's app engine.
And it consists of
two components.
The first is the front end.
It's the embeddable YouTube
Direct container.
We use Google's AuthSub to
authenticate users to their
YouTube account.
And from your website, users
can actually submit videos
using the YouTube back end,
and they can submit photos
that get submitted to Picasa.
On the back end for the editors,
for the reviewers,
there's an admin interface
that allows you to create
assignments to review and accept
or reject the video and
photo submissions that come in,
and really just manage how
all of these different assets
appear on your site.
So here's an example of
a partner integration.
Our partners here, KGO ABC 7
here in the Bay area, we
partnered with them starting
last summer on a really cool
citizen journalism project
that's called uReport.
This version of uReport had
YouTube Direct where users
could come to their site and
actually upload videos, you
can see, into various
categories.
So they could select breaking
news, or there were also
different types of submission
categories that users could
then upload them to.
Here's an example of how this
is displayed on their site,
again, using the YouTube API
to display these videos on
their website, on ABC 7.
And here's a screenshot of what
the admin panel looks
like for YouTube Direct.
So these are all a list of
submissions that came in
through both the mobile app,
which I'll show you a
screenshot of in a second, as
well as the web interface.
And the editorial web team over
it at KGO actually would
go through and review these
videos and decide which ones
they wanted to use on air, and
which ones they wanted to
display on their website, and
which ones just didn't fit or
were not appropriate to
the call to action.
And here's a quick
screenshot--
a very bad screenshot--
of our mobile app,
which was a total beta.
We just wanted to test it out,
but we had 150 what we call
citizen stringers out in the
field who are actually using
these mobile applications to see
submission ideas and then
submit videos directly related
to those various topics.
So, my time's up.
Thank you.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thank you
Olivia, and I would like to
invite Storyful to
present next.
GAVIN SHERIDAN: So just
a warning, I'm
a hack, not a hacker.
And I think that means
I'm more dangerous, I
don't know, or less.
I'm not sure.
And so I'm going to play
this in Prezi.
So I'm going to start by saying
that at Storyful where--
my name Gavin Sheridan, by the
way, and I'm from a company
called Storyful.
We're based in Dublin
in Ireland.
And we're also YouTube's
curation partner for
CitizenTube,
youtube.com/citizentube.
So we're a social media news
agency, and we monitor
YouTube every day.
We monitor YouTube
for videos from--
particularly in the last six
months-- from the Arab Spring.
And we spend a great deal of
time watching YouTube videos.
Our own back end system in
relation to the API, we spend
a great deal of time on
searching, persistent
searching, understanding what
we search for, sourcing
uploaders, where they're from,
messaging people who've
uploaded videos that we
find interesting.
And I'm just going to show a
video here that was uploaded
to YouTube just over
two weeks ago.
And it's a bit dramatic, so
I hope you don't mind.
I was going to play the
first minute of it, if
it plays for me.
I think the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
is going to work, is it?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Now I'm going to stop there.
It gets a little bit more
graphic later, but it's
important to remember why we're
watching these kind of
videos and why these videos
are important.
So this is kind of a mantra
of journalists
all over the world.
"I keep six honest-serving
men.
They taught me all I knew.
Their names are What and Why and
When and How and Where and
Who."
So the first question I ask
myself when I see a video like
that is what can I understand
from that?
And what answers can I
gain from that video?
So how many of those questions
can we answer just by looking
at this video, before we contact
anybody, before we
contact anybody who's uploaded
the video, what can we learn
from looking at it?
So the first question I'm going
to ask is where was that
video taken?
Now it was taken in Syria, so if
that's your starting point
the original uploader did-- the
same video was re-uploaded
several times-- so we have to
try and understand which city
was this taken in.
Some videos had said it was Hama
some videos said it was
Homs, but we were leaning
towards Al-Kseer
as the upload location.
So this is the town
of Al-Kseer.
If you remember, the video's
pretty dramatic.
You watched the people running,
there's shooting
going on, it's all
very dramatic.
But I was looking at
something else.
I was looking at what were the
buildings in the background?
What time of day was it?
Where was this being filmed?
So you zoom in on Al-Kseer on
Google Earth and you can see
there's pretty prominent area
in the middle here is a
government-owned land because
you can see there's a cemetery
here and there's pretty
prominent buildings.
And if you re-orient that
looking east you could begin
to see that this might be where
the video was filmed.
And so you're trying to
answer the question of
where it was filmed.
So at the start of the video
you see this building.
That's probably that building
on Google Earth.
When you're looking south,
there's that video on a
billboard in the corner.
That's probably that
building and that
billboard in the corner.
When you're looking west there's
a tree in the middle
of the street with a tall
building in the back.
That's probably that tree and
that building in the back.
And as you're looking north you
see another building with
a little thing on the top of it,
and you can see the same
building looking north.
So when you get to the end of
it you can see that this is
the general path the
videographer
took when he was walking.
These are the buildings that
were in the video.
And we're answering the question
of where it was.
So on the balance of
probabilities this was taken
at Al-Kseer, probably in the
last couple of weeks.
But once you've found
out where your next
question then is when?
So can we answer the question
when this was taken?
Once we've established that
it's Al-Kseer we can start
searching and see is this video
being discussed or is
the town of Al-Kseer being
discussed in the context of
the time this was taken?
And you can see here they're
discussing it.
The military had moved into
Al-Kseer on the 24th of June.
So it's after that
date, probably.
And we're trying to find out the
answer to this question.
On a blog this was being
discussed and they say that
the Syrian army had moved into
Al-Kseer on the 24th.
There was a Tweet on 24th of
June from Ham Farouk saying,
heavy machine guns are being
used to shoot on protesters in
bystreets and on houses
in the city of Kseer.
So that's backing up
the 24th of June.
This same video is being
discussed on a Syrian
revolution Facebook page.
Having been discussed in Arabic,
we translate that back
into English to see what
discussion's going
on about the video.
And if you look at this
picture, this is what
confirmed to us that this was
taken on the 24th of June and
not, as some people thought,
on the 1st of July.
This was a satellite photograph
taken five days
after, and it was uploaded to
Google Earth this week.
And you can see the same
location but the topography
has changed.
And you can see down at the
bottom, there there's a small
vehicle in the bottom right.
That's probably an APC because
you can measure the
dimensions of it.
It's three meters across,
nine meters long.
And there's a barrier
being put up on
the side of the street.
So that photograph was
taken five days later
on the 29th of June.
And that means that the video
was filmed at Al-Kseer, it was
taken on the 24th of June.
And we can answer two questions
before we even
approach the people who've
uploaded the video or approach
our sources in Syria and say,
where was this video taken,
what does it depict?
So we've answered two major
questions just by
understanding, searching for
videos using the API to our
system and then going through a
process of looking at them.
And I think the significance
of this--
I mean, it's applying very
traditional values to
journalism, to traditional
journalistic values, that is,
but using technology to answer
those questions that
I put at the start.
So in Storyful we always
live by two mantras.
The first is that
there's always
somebody closer to story.
And the second is that every
event creates a community.
Every event creates a community,
whether it's a
Facebook page, whether it's a
Facebook comment, whether it's
a tweet, whether it's
a comment on a
video, whether it's--
Everything creates
a community.
And it's about being able to
understand that community and
exploit it to understand
and contextualize
content like that.
And I suppose the final question
I suppose here is
what time of day was it?
So by the shadows going in that
direction and being able
to understand the north,
south, east direction
orientations of the video, it
was taken around 3 or 4
o'clock in the afternoon.
And that's
YouTube.com/CitizenTube.
We're storyful.com.
I'm @gavinsblog and @storyful
is our tweet.
Thank you.
XAVIER DAMMAN: So hi everyone.
I'm Xavier Damman, the
co-founder of Storify with
Bert Herman.
So those are really great
presentations.
We really believe that we are
living in this new golden age
of journalism.
For the first time in human
history we have not only a few
thousand reporters around the
world we have actually half a
billion reporters.
And thanks to that, now we can
know what's happening in
Syria, in Egypt but also when
there is a tornado in America.
There is always someone on the
scene that's going to report
on YouTube, or Twitter, or
Facebook, or Google Press
what's really happening.
So this is really awesome.
And so everybody's a reporter
but not everybody is a
journalist. And we really need
journalists more than ever to
actually make sense of
what's happening.
And so other question is when
you see all this great
content, the video that has just
been shown, for example,
the question becomes how can
we publish that content so
that our audience, your audience
as journalists, can
benefit from that content,
and you can touch them.
And so this is really what
Storify is all about is we
really want to make Storify the
bridge, the typewriter,
for this new social media age.
So just create a story, and this
is the way it looks like.
You have your story on the
right-hand side, and then on
the left-hand side you have
access to different APIs, to
different sources, Twitter,
Facebook, YouTube.
And I can search for, let's say
hacks and hackers here.
And I can find [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
out to the YouTube API, and I
can just find things that are
interesting, and I can just drag
and drop into my story.
So I don't need to deal with all
those API codes and things
like that, I just
drag and drop.
And I can add text anywhere in
between, do my blog post and
tell the story like, this
is what's happening.
With it, you can tell your own
narrative and you can add what
also people are saying
on Twitter.
For example here.
Here we go.
I'm going to add--
what story?--
nice quote from David here.
And so you can really augment
your story using what people
on the ground are sharing.
And so once you do
that you can-- so
YouTube API, Meetup here--
once you do that you can select
a different story, a
different thumbnail then you
publish your story and you get
this story that you can embed
anywhere you want.
You can embed it on your site.
And for example here, we have
the Toronto Star, who created
a story with Japan tornado and
taking what people posted
about the tornado on YouTube.
Or we have here the Washington
Post, also using Storify to
publish that content and really
create a new kind of
story that really has a
different kind of impact.
Because it's something to send
a reporter after the fact
that's going to take a
professional picture, but then
when you have a picture like
this one where it's actually
you can see the church being
destroyed, and it's actually
someone who says, this is where
I got married, and my
best friend came and
went to school.
I mean it's something that has
definitely a different
emotional impact on
your audience.
And this is what journalism
is all about.
It's about informing your
audience of what's happening
and trying to get them feel
some empathy about what
happened, and really care about
the message that you
want to get across.
So once you publish your
story so you can
embed it on your site.
But you can also notify the
people that you've quoted.
So now I can let David
know that actually
he's part of the story.
And people love that.
And they receive a tweet and
again will re-tweet that
because they want to tell
everybody, hey, that's so
cool, I'm now part
of the story.
And so it really helps your
story go viral, which is
really something important now
in this new social media age.
Because we talk so much about
APIs, we have a lot of APIs.
If you're a hacker, actually,
by just appending at the end
of the story that JSON you
actually get access to the
JSON representation
of the story.
And thanks to that you can
create a great visualization
of your story.
For example I can just turn that
story into a slide show
by appending /slideshow at
the end of the story.
And so now this is
my great text.
You can see I'm a hacker
and not a hack.
But now I've got here
this Tweet.
I just add it, and also
the YouTube video.
Here we go.
And the resolution of the
screen is not the
best one to show that.
So you get the idea.
So we can really create great
social media stories and tell
your audience what's happening
using content from all those
social networks and YouTube.
And my time is up.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thank
you Xavier.
Great presentation.
Great story.
And, yes, I think we have
ShortForm next.
Is this on?
And I think you guys have a--
NADER GHAFFARI: While
he pulls that up,
who's heard of ShortForm?
Oh, I see some hands.
Great.
Hi my name is Nader Ghaffari.
I'm the CEO of ShortForm.
I'm here with my
co-founders Tom
Collier and Jereme Monteau.
As Jarek said earlier, today
over eight years of online
video content is uploaded to the
internet every single day.
That's eight years.
What we do at ShortForm is we
transform all that video into
the most social and interactive
online video
experience on the web.
On ShortForm, you can either
be a VJ, a viewer, or both.
VJs curate the world's videos
into continuous channels and
share them with viewers.
Viewers subscribe and tune in
to channels of interest, and
consume a continuous stream
while interacting with viewers
and VJs while they consume.
We've got channels on every
subject imaginable.
People are curating channels
around their favorite videos.
Relevant to today's topic, most
new stories eventually
get a channel.
We had channels around Egypt,
Libya, the Japan tsunami.
And Tom will in fact
show a channel on a
local weather station.
We can be found today on
shortform.com and through an
embeddable widget, which brings
curated videos to any
publisher out there with
continuous streams of video.
And with that I'll pass it to
my co-founder, Jereme, who
will talk about making
a channel.
JEREME MONTEAU: The lead
developer, so--
Thanks Nader-- got a little
narration there.
I'm Jereme, lead developer
at ShortForm form.
ShortForm is a great way to
curate online video into your
own channels.
Getting started is
really easy.
You just sign up at
shortform.com and you can
start adding videos.
We've made it possible to add
videos from all over the web,
but I think given the setting,
I'll talk about YouTube in
particular.
Now OAuth is a protocol that
allows web applications to
make secure API calls on
behalf of the user.
You can find out more
at oauth.net.
YouTube has implemented OAuth
for their data API, and we've
integrated with it.
And so the result is that it's
really easy to connect your
YouTube account to ShortForm.
It's a matter of just clicking
on a button in our UI, logging
into YouTube, and then approving
our application.
At that point you can login to
ShortForm with your YouTube
account and you can import
videos into your channel from
your YouTube account.
Now the nice thing about OAuth
is it allows you to grant and
revoke access on a
per-application basis.
So if for some reason you
decide later that an
application shouldn't be able
to get your data anymore you
can just go in and revoke it.
But you won't do that
with ShortForm.
Anyways, after you connect your
account to ShortForm, you
can import videos from your
list of favorite videos on
YouTube or the list of videos
you've uploaded.
Behind the scenes, we make
secure calls to the YouTube
data API to bring those
into our UI.
You can add videos from any
other YouTube user, you just
enter their username and you can
import their videos all at
once, or you can be
more selective
with our user interface.
Once you've got a channel going,
you can share it on
shortform.com or you can
distribute it across the web
with our embeddable widget.
And that's what our CTO
Tom Collier is going
to talk about next.
Thanks.
TOM COLLIER: Thanks Jereme.
So I'm Tom Collier.
I'm the CTO of ShortForm, and
like Jereme mentioned, I'm
going to talk a little bit more
about the ShortForm of
embeddable widget, and I'll also
touch upon some of the
integration points we have
with the YouTube API.
So there's a prominent weather
blogger in the Pacific
Northwest, who we're using as
an example here, who has
embedded our widget
on his site.
And you can see that the videos
on this widget add a
little bit a life to the
text-based content of his blog
post.
So this is about a tornado that
happened recently, and
you can see the videos are all
related to the particular
topic that the blogger
is blogging about.
And as one video ends we
seamlessly transition to the
next video.
If the viewer is not so into
the video he's currently
watching he's able to browse
the channel through the
thumbnails below the player and
select a video he might
want to watch instead.
As you see, the most prominent
part of the embeddable widget
is the YouTube player.
And we've actually integrated
with YouTube's iframe API
player, which is still labeled
experimental but we've found
works really well in a
production environment.
And the nice thing about the
iframe player is that it
chooses dynamically whether
wants to use a flash-based
player or a HTML5-based
player.
So it actually works on a lot
of platforms including IOS
devices like the iPad.
We do integrate with other video
players but we find that
the YouTube player is the
most fully featured.
It gives us full programmatic
control of the video so we can
play and pause, and also
dynamically load in new videos
as we see fit, whether we're
transitioning to the next
video or if the user selects
a different video.
It also gives us a full set
of video state callbacks.
So if a video is unavailable
for whatever reason, if it
were taken down or if a user
marked it unembeddable we can
tell the server to update the
channel and dynamically move
the video on.
So if you want to learn more
about the ShortForm embeddable
widget visit
shortform.com/widget.
And we'd like to thank Jarek
and the YouTube folks for
having us here.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thank you
for the nice demo and
presentation, and accolades.
That's pretty awesome.
Next we have GoAnimate,
I believe.
Is Gary in the room?
All right.
Just start the clock.
You've got five minutes.
GARY LIPKOWITZ: Hi everybody.
My name is Gary Lipkowitz,
and I'm with GoAnimate.
Just a quick overview.
GoAnimate is a suite of web
apps, located at goaimate.com,
that allows everybody to quickly
and easily create
animated videos.
Most importantly, no drawing
or programming is required.
And I've got on here simple drag
and drop apps, but the
easiest one is actually a
text-to-video app where you
literally type your video and
we take care of the rest.
We've done a lot of
work with YouTube.
We're part of youtube/create,
and we've also used the data
APIs to enable our subscribers
to very seamlessly export
their videos to YouTube.
The connection to reporting?
I've written a couple
of things up here.
Certainly if you wanted to put
yourself into a virtual
studio, this would be a very
easy template to create quick
and easy studio sets.
Although it's a full-featured
suite of web apps, this does
allow you to import video,
audio, or any other digital
assets into the studio
environment to be incorporated
into the assets that
we have there.
For instance, audio journalists
or bloggers could
very easily translate their
material into a video and
publish it.
It's a freemium model, and
there's plenty to work with on
the free side.
Most importantly, on the
news-related side I'd say this
allows you-- or provides a forum
in which you can very
easily comment on the news.
And I'll show you a
little video to
illustrate that at the end.
I'd just like to quickly show
you the three apps that are in
our environment.
The simplest one is the
text-to-video app.
I'm sure many of you have seen
little videos running around
YouTube often with millions
of views where a couple of
animated or robot voice
characters argue with each
other over mobile operating
systems, or stuff like that.
So there's two providers in that
space both of them are on
youtube/create for your
creation pleasure.
You can see there's a three
at the top of the screen.
So the way it works in
our environment,
you choose a theme--
that's kind of a matching
set of backgrounds, and
characters, and props-- so you
choose a theme, then you
choose your characters.
The robot voices in this app are
married to the characters,
so you don't even have
to worry about that.
Then you type your dialogue,
then you press play.
Literally you could be done in
a minute, but they would be
robot-voiced.
And I really messed around
trying to find ways these
robot voices can tell jokes
and do one-liners.
There's ways with punctuation,
you can mess around with it.
But if you want to be more
creative than text-to-video
the next step is the
character creator.
How many people have a Wii, and
have used the Mii creator
on the Wii?
All right.
So you guys are all
ready to go.
You can use the character
creator right away.
You can see here we're
choosing the
top half of his clothing.
If we right arrow we
would then move on.
You see the icon
of the pants--
or hopefully you can see
it on this screen.
You would then choose that, then
you choose shoes, then
eyebrows, nose, facial
hair, ears, earrings.
Not only can you choose
different things off the
pallet you can make them bigger,
smaller, rotate them.
If your Mr. Spock has to have
his pointy ears exactly at a
certain angle you can do that,
and you can get it done in
about five seconds.
When you're really ready to make
a full-featured video you
would go into the animation
studio.
This is what the pallet
looks like.
Like I said, it's all point,
click, drag and drop tools.
You can see a drop down
menu with the theme.
Below that, icons for character,
callout buttons if
you're try to do a comic strip
style, backgrounds, props,
music and sound effects, and
then visual effects.
Shoot.
I'm real short on time so I
want to quickly try to get
this video to you.
And I hope we can--
shoot, that is the wrong--
That's not copied correctly.
Where was the presentation?
Was it this one.
Shoot.
Failed again.
BERT HERMAN: Do you
want me to try it?
GARY LIPKOWITZ: Yes, please.
BERT HERMAN: This is my mic,
and this one a special.
GARY LIPKOWITZ: This video is
a sneak peek of the new
topical theme that we're
bringing into the production
environment.
As many as you know, in this
country we elect a president
every four years.
And usually the party not in
power gets started by having
multiple candidates in what's
called the primary, and then
they have a lot of debates
before you get
to the general election.
I'm deliberately talking
like we're in primary
school to kill time.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for joining
us this evening.
Welcome to the future of
presidential primaries and
elections brought to you by
YouTube and GoAnmate.
-Please welcome former
Massachusetts
governor Mitt Romney.
-Compared to the other
candidates you will meet
tonight, I'm twice as strong
on the issues.
That's because I stand on
both sides of them.
-Please welcome Congressman
Ron Paul.
-If elected president of the
United States, I pledge to
immediately abolish said office
as well as the entire
federal government.
-Texas Governor Rick Perry.
-If elected, I will
intelligently design the
government and execute as many
criminals as executive orders.
-And finally, the Drilla
from Wasilla.
The highly publicized
vacation-taker Sarah Palin.
-Alaska was small potatoes.
My commitment to the office
of President is strong.
I promise not to resign until
the public speaking money gets
really, really, really good.
-And there you have it.
Brief introductions from
all our candidates.
If you don't like what they're
saying, change it using
YouTube and GoAnimate.
I'll now leave the stage since
zombies are coming to eat the
candidates.
Thank you for joining us.
Drive safely and have
a good night.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
HANNAH EAVES: Hi.
That's kind of a tough act to
follow, but I'm going to do my
best. So I'm going to try and
start this with a bit of a
statement from a well known
provocateur, Clay Shirky here.
And he says, "If I was going
to start a news business
tomorrow, I would start a news
business designed to produce
not one new bit of news.
But instead to aggregate news
for individuals in ways that
matter to them."
And I think that that is really
revealing of a new
opportunity that's come about
recently thanks to this
creation of a whole
new system of vast
syndication of video content.
So if you look at YouTube, in
a lot of ways YouTube is a
vast syndicator.
It's a huge library of content
that multiple people can use
in different ways, through
APIs and through
an embeddable player.
Now Link TV, probably a lot of
you aren't familiar with us,
but we are a national satellite
broadcaster in about
35 million US households.
And for a long time, one of
our areas of expertise has
been content curation.
And not just content curation,
but the ability to add
additional added value to the
content that we select.
So a lot of the content that
we select is international
news, international
documentaries, world cinema.
And then we have programs such
as Mosaic World News from the
Middle East, which is a daily
half-hour program where we
select eight to 10 broadcasts
from Middle Eastern
broadcasters, and then we
translate those into English.
And it's a combination of
curation and aggregation with
this extra valued content, which
is that you're then able
to hear what it is that the
Middle East is saying about
the United States, and see
opinions from people on the
ground in the Middle East and
broadcasters in the Middle
East. We have a similar program
called Link Asia,
which does a similar kind
of thing with Asian news
programming, except that it also
uses blogger contributors
from Asian countries.
Now what we've decided
to do with Link
News is a new website.
We've realized that there is
this new opportunity around
curation and added value.
And so we've created a new
website that's heavily based
on those concepts.
So I'd rather just show you the
website than talk about
this stuff.
Can I get into the--
Here we go.
Yep.
There we go.
So here's a homepage
of Link News.
This is a new site that
we just launched.
As you can see that this is a
broad variety of content from
a whole bunch of different
broadcasters--
international broadcasters--
Al Jazeera English, Telegraph
UK, ITN News, Euro News.
And in a lot of ways this looks
like a traditional news
website, an international
news video website.
But what's powering this website
is the YouTube API.
So every single piece of content
you see here featured
on the home page has been
curated from the library of
content at YouTube.
Every morning we have a news
editor that comes and searches
for the best and most
interesting stories that are
breaking in the world, and also
looks for angles that
might not be covered in the
mainstream media, or stories
that might fall through
the cracks.
For instance, UN declares
famine in Somalia.
But what we're doing differently
to a lot of sites
that use the YouTube API--
and you could see it in a lot
of the projects tonight--
is that we're integrating fully
the YouTube experience
into the news experience.
So if you click on one
of these videos--
and we have one down
here that seemed
appropriate for tonight--
"Hacks and Hackers: LulzSec
Attacks Murdoch Newspaper."
This is a YouTube video.
You can see it has a YouTube
watermark here.
It plays through YouTube's
chromeless player, but it has
all of our own controls, all of
our own video controls, and
it looks just like a video
from our own system.
When we call that video into
our system we bring with it
all the metadata that
comes from YouTube.
So here we have the title,
description, and that's where
the added value starts
coming in.
Our system, which is a unique
system, it analyzes the
metadata, the title,
description, transcript, any
other kind of information that
comes with the video, and it
automatically pulls out topics
and tags that are related to
that video.
So it has an intelligent
analysis that says, this video
is about Rupert Murdoch,
LulzSec, news international,
anonymous, hacker, hacktivism.
And this is automated.
You know, at most news websites
someone would
manually come through and tag
this video, but this is an
automated system, an intelligent
system, and that
means that it's highly
scalable.
So we can have just one person
part-time curating a massive
news website because this
system is automated.
In addition to that we use those
topics then to bring in
related content from
around the web.
So here we have articles
from around the web.
And we have related videos from
other websites such as--
we can bring in videos from Wall
Street Journal, CBS, ABC.
And then in addition we have a
supporting articles, Gawker.
So when this story broke this
system not only featured this
video about this story, but
intelligently brought in the
best information from all
around the web to
support this story.
And that information updates
itself live the minute someone
watches this video, which means
that we turn a site that
is a basic video site into
an incredibly rich media
experience adding a whole extra
level of information
around the video.
In addition these topics all
lead to advance topic pages.
So it gives you information
about that topic, information
about the individual, and again,
all sorts of videos
from around the web, videos
from Link TV, around this
topic area.
And also the ability
to narrow down.
So you're looking at Rupert
Murdoch you might want to see
what the Australian Prime
Minister had to say about
Rupert Murdoch's recent
behavior.
So you can narrow it down.
It does an intelligent analysis
of all the videos
that have been categorized
as Rupert Murdoch videos.
What are the secondary
categories?
And it suggests where
you might want to
narrow down your focus.
So here now we're just seeing
news story videos from around
the web about the Australians
Prime Minister's reaction to
Rupert Murdoch.
And of course topic pages like
this are incredibly great for
search engine optimization and
all sorts of other techniques
to bring larger audiences
to your video content.
So I think that I'm
out of time.
But that does give you kind of
an overview this isn't a more
traditional video website but
it's just a deeply integrated,
curatorial-level on top
of YouTube's content.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thank
you, Hannah.
And I'm going to hand it off to
Bert now, who will run our
Q&A session.
And I would like to invite our
presenters to come up closer
to the podium so you guys can
take questions with us.
Thank you.
BERT HERMAN: Yeah.
Thanks a lot to all
of the presenters.
That was really great.
I saw actually one question
on Twitter.
I thought maybe I would start
with Olivia, actually, because
somebody said, oh,
I didn't realize
YouTube had a news director.
Maybe you should even just say
a little bit briefly about
what you do on a daily basis.
OLIVIA MA: I wouldn't
get caught
calling myself a director.
Yeah.
No, YouTube has a small
but mighty news team.
There's just a couple of us
and we're obviously not
focused on creating content.
YouTube doesn't create
content.
But really what we do is try
and create programs,
partnerships, and products
that help both news
organizations as well as
individual journalists and
citizen reporters-- we use
that phrase not citizen
journalists--
use YouTube more effectively
to disseminate information.
So we actually have another
person from our team Dave
Gehring, who's in the back--
Dave, raise your hand--
who's our strategic partner
manager for our news
organization.
So he works directly with news
partners on the site and help
them optimize their channels
and their experience for
distributing their content,
whereas I'm more on the side
of working with the community
and trying to bridge the gap
between news organizations and
these citizen reporters.
So that's what we do.
BERT HERMAN: Questions please.
All of you here you don't
have any questions?
You're blown away by the--
yeah, Jack.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: A couple questions
but I'll take my turn.
The first question goes to the
last. The related videos,
doesn't YouTube have a related
videos feed in the API?
And do you guys do a better
job of the related videos?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BERT HERMAN: I'm going to just
repeat the question actually
just to make everybody hears, So
the question is YouTube has
a related videos API.
How do they work with that
or is there something
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
HANNAH EAVES: Well YouTube's
related content API is limited
to content that's on YouTube.
What we do is we link
to content from
all across the web.
So it's not just videos that
are on YouTube it's videos
from all over the place.
And also, I would say using the
semantic technology we use
also provides in some
ways, perhaps,
better related content.
I don't want to say that I'm
better than Google because
that sounds kind of ridiculous,
but we are doing a
lot of really advanced work
with semantic entities and
link data that mean that it
does kind of a good job.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I would like
to add that the application is
actually open source, so for
all of you hackers you are
welcome to download it.
I think a fair amount of
the work is actually
available right now.
And you can hack with it and
see how well it works.
And then I don't think we have
a monopoly of the best video
selection ever, and this is
precisely why we want
application developer partners
so they can do their own share
of discovering the content
on YouTube.
HANNAH EAVES: Yeah.
And I would say it's
not all us.
We use about--
how many different APIs?
Our developers are over here--
five or six different
APIs as part of the
whole application process.
AUDIENCE: Quick question
to you.
The data API, some of the
data not's updating.
It's been something that's going
on with channel views,
data views?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So the view
counts are not always updating
in real time.
They will eventually return
the consistent
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Well, it's not something we
discussed as far as the actual
implementation.
But yeah, if our algorithms
detect that there maybe some
issues with the view count,
then we kind of take a
conservative approach.
But eventually they do coverage
on the right number.
AUDIENCE: Kind of a follow up
on that and then I have
another question.
I know Google uses the search
API in its videos.
What's interesting and my
question is do you guys do
customization in the app and
that maybe something you could
develop later?
Could they could choose
what sources they
want for their dashboard?
That's really a cool app because
you can do custom
searches [INAUDIBLE].
BERT HERMAN: So the question
was if they can customize--
a viewer can customize
the sources they see.
And I'm going to say we're going
to keep it to just one
question per person.
HANNAH EAVES: We don't right
now but we have the
architecture in the back end to
support that in the future.
We do have a weighting system
for sources that we use
internally, but definitely
interested in the idea of
making that available
to users.
AUDIENCE: This is for the
panel in general.
This is such fabulous, powerful
tools [INAUDIBLE],
but I'm wondering how will media
professionals continue
to get paid?
BERT HERMAN: How do
people get paid?
DAVID CLINCH: Can
I answer that?
BERT HERMAN: Sure.
Go ahead.
DAVID CLINCH: Hi.
I'm David Clinch.
And I'm with Gavin and Mike from
Storyful here as well.
And the answer is, I'm one
of those professionals.
I worked at CNN for 20 years and
left with no other plan in
my pocket except to start a
company that would do the news
in a completely new way.
My co-founder, Mark Little, was
exactly the same, 20 years
of doing journalism.
As far as we're concerned, we're
still doing journalism.
So what we did, and what Gavin
did a great job of showing you
there with the video that we
identified, that's just one
piece of video.
We do hundreds.
AUDIENCE: Pardon me for asking,
but how are you paid?
DAVID CLINCH: News companies
pay Storyful--
that's a very good question
because we didn't really
address that-- news companies,
some of the largest news
companies in the world, pay
Storyful a subscription to get
our services, curated video,
sent in a stream directly to
their news room with all of the
information they need not
just to identify videos like
that from Syria, which are
obviously then verified by us,
but also videos of tornadoes,
of floods, of anything else,
with all of the information
that we can get from the API but
also what we get from our
own curation, which would be
telephone numbers, emails,
verification that would help
the news companies then
immediately get the person, who
is literally still sitting
on the plane taking a picture
of the shuttle taking off
through the clouds, before
they even leave the plane
they're getting phone calls from
news companies saying,
can we use your picture?
So they pay us for
the service, we
don't own the content.
HANNAH EAVES: Can I take just a
quick stab at this as well?
BERT HERMAN: You can take
a stab at that.
Yeah, there was some--
HANNAH EAVES: I know that this
revenue source is not catching
up, so this is a bit of
disingenuous answer, but you
know there is advertising
on YouTube videos.
And that comes with the videos
when we use them on the site.
So there is opportunities with
syndication for your ads to
reach a much, much, much
larger audience if the
syndication happens to
the right places
with the right numbers.
It could boost your ad revenue
significantly.
And also there is potential,
eventually--
we're doing news but we're
also doing documentaries.
Say you're watching a news
story about the nuclear
reactor breakdown in Japan, and
you really want to watch a
documentary about
nuclear energy.
Maybe that documentary is on
Hulu Plus, but maybe the site
allows you to plug in your
credentials via various
subscription services.
And so you could then, if all
worked well in the syndication
world, you could watch that
content on a site like ours by
plugging in your paid
subscription to other services.
NADER GHAFFARI: At ShortForm we
actually think Jereme had
once Tweeted curation
is the new creation.
When you've got eight years of
content being uploaded we
actually intend to distribute
some of our revenue to the VJs
who actually curate
these channels.
So when you have socially
programed channels and these
VJs are finding the right
content for their audience,
and they build and audience, we
intend to reward them for
finding an audience, building
an audience, just like a
television network would if they
had built an audience.
And our revenue model's to
interstitial place ads within
the channels.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
for the Storyful folks.
Your video is very dramatic and
you talked about how you
get to who, how, when, where,
why, et cetera.
But that looked like a very
time-consuming process.
Do you have cool software tools
to make you able to do
it much, much quicker than
you might think?
GAVIN SHERIDAN: It
often depends--
BERT HERMAN: The question,
let me just
repeat it since, yeah--
So the question was Storyful,
it looks like it's a very
time-consuming process.
Do they have any software
that makes that easier?
GAVIN SHERIDAN: It depends
on the videos,
really, is the answer.
And that particular video I was
able to find out where it
was filmed relatively--
it took about 15 minutes because
if you become attuned
to be able to identify
stuff in videos--
and as I said, it depends
on the video.
Some videos it's much harder
to identify location, it's
much harder to identify
landmarks, it's much harder to
identify the time of day,
and that kind of thing.
So yeah, oftentimes you're
leveraging a social graph that
develops around content so
you're actually letting people
help you understand what
the content is saying.
So easier using the crowds to
some degree to understand the
discussion that's
forming around--
As I said, content and videos
like this create communities.
Even singular events
create community.
So you're reaching out to people
subsequently and you're
saying, is this video showing
what I think it's showing?
And you're trying to reach to a
balance of probabilities and
saying, I think this is a fair
stab at trying to understand
what's going on.
DAVID CLINCH: I would also say
that process you saw and that
Gavin described, we have dubbed
it the human algorithm.
So while we do have quite
sophisticated back end systems
that help us do one thing that's
very important, and
that is we can quickly identify
those videos that we
should be spending time on and
not the hundreds or thousands
that we should not be
spending time on.
So we can then dedicate the
human algorithm part, which is
both our curation and the
community that's around it, to
the process that might
take 15 minutes or it
might take five minutes.
And then, of course, the more
you do it in some ways the
easier it gets.
AUDIENCE: I've got a question
for the hacker from Storify.
I really like your idea
and I could see myself
using it in my blog.
I write technical articles,
how-tos, tutorials--
But the question was, you showed
in YouTube you can type
in somebody's username
and pull all of
their videos and stuff.
What about copyright issues
where people, it belongs to
somebody but you can't use it
without their permission.
How do you handle that?
And with YouTube-- you know,
you can mark it private.
Does the API provide the whole
list of videos for the user or
how does that work out?
BERT HERMAN: A question
for Storify
about copyright issues.
Good thing he has
to answer it.
XAVIER DAMMAN: Thanks.
Yeah.
So there is some interesting
things there.
So obviously when you upload a
video to YouTube you can set
the privacy settings, and so you
can allow or disallow the
being able to embed the video.
So it's really like, if you can
embed the video, then it's
going to be embedded.
And if you cannot embed the
video it is going to be you
can embed it and then show that
actually the owner of the
video didn't want to
embed the video.
And that may be interesting.
I don't know if you remember the
golden voice, there's the
famous guy who actually was the
homeless person who has an
amazing voice.
And so someone took a video of
that and uploaded that to
YouTube and then someone did a
Storify story about it that
really went viral.
And then after a while, I don't
know, the rights were
bought or something.
But anyway, long story short,
the video was not available
anymore for embedding.
And so the person, the author
of the story, updated the
story and says, oh, well now
we don't have the right
anymore to publish that video.
Which is also kind of part of
the story, the fact that
someone actually took over the
rights and actually decided
not to publish it anymore.
AUDIENCE: But then you can
link them to your--
that YouTube--
XAVIER DAMMAN: Yes.
We can always link
back anyway.
So through the API we have also
access to the information
whether you can embed it
or not, or whether
it's private or not.
And it is a fundamental aspect
of Storify, which is the fact
that we always keep
a link back to the
original piece of content.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I would
liked to add one common.
So through the API, you can
discover whether the video has
been allowed for embedding
or not.
And we do give content owners
the ability to actually
prevent people from embedding
the video.
So they can upload it but
you can only see it on
youtube.com, for example.
And then actually as far as the
copyright and stuff like
that, I'm not a lawyer but I
would like to mention also
that recently we added the
ability to indicate upon the
upload what type of licensing
you would like your video to
have. In fact you can designate
creative commons as
the license for the video that
you upload to YouTube, and you
can do that today.
AUDIENCE: What about like a--
BERT HERMAN: Just one
question, sorry.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So we can
chat after the event.
BERT HERMAN: Other questions?
AUDIENCE: For YouTube Direct,
can you just talk more about
how the program's been going,
and some insights like have
people been submitting great
videos or have the editors
been inundated with videos
that aren't as cool.
OLIVIA MA: Yeah.
No, it's a good question.
BERT HERMAN: A question
about YouTube Direct.
What kinds of videos are
people uploading?
Is it a lot of noise?
Are people being inundated?
OLIVIA MA: So the team from
KGO is actually here, so I
encourage you to find
them after.
With that project in particular,
I think they
definitely saw a fairly
significant
increase in video content.
They already had a
user-generated program that
they had launched a few months
earlier, and had seen a lot of
photo uploads.
I think it's easier for people
to take photos with their
mobile phone.
And so with this with this
program they definitely saw a
notable uptick in video
submissions, which for a
television station is pretty
useful, right?
Because video content is more
interesting to show on a
nightly news than photos.
I do think that video
is harder, right?
It's harder to get good
quality stuff
when you ask for it.
And I still think that the
balance of YouTube is fairly
significantly weighted towards
what's organically showing up
versus what you ask for.
I think that that's why a lot
of these applications that
people are talking about today
are so interesting is because
using the YouTube API you can
search and find the stuff that
people are uploading
to YouTube.
Because they may not know about
that news organization
that's asking for it.
So we still strongly encourage
news organizations to look on
YouTube to see what they can
find that's just being
uploaded because not everyone's
going to know, oh,
I should go to this news
organization's
site to submit this.
But we have noticed that if a
news organization really does
dedicate themselves to investing
in the community and
asking for stuff on a
regular basis, it
really has to do with--
KGO really promoted that on
air and said, send us your
stuff, we want it.
And every day they said that,
so their audience started to
understand, OK, this station
really does want my content.
That really does pay off
in the long run.
BERT HERMAN: Yep.
Back there.
AUDIENCE: Are there any viewer
tools around to allow viewers
to establish their preferences
and make a virtual channel?
[INAUDIBLE]
BERT HERMAN: So the question was
about viewer tools, ways
to share things with their
social networks.
NADER GHAFFARI: That's
essentially where we're at
with ShortForm.
it is social video so where
we're going is you would
arrive at ShortForm and you
would know exactly which
channels your friends have
watched or are currently in,
and you would have the ability
to join those channels and
watch with them synchronously
and consume that content.
So we are absolutely going in
that direction of social video
and opening it up fully
to your graph.
DAVID CLINCH: And I would just
like to add-- this a bit
provocative, but I think things
like that are very
interesting and that certainly
it is great within the context
of a particular group or company
but I'm particularly
interested in perhaps the role
that Google Plus might take
going forward particularly
because it's a Google product
and YouTube will presumably be
as integrated as it could
possibly be.
And it's very interesting for us
at Storyful, for instance,
to think that right now we're
using Twitter, and Facebook,
and lots of different platforms
that are circling
around the YouTube video, but it
would be really interesting
to us to imagine a situation
where a YouTube video could
actually be framed within Google
Plus and all of that
functionality of discussion,
and sharing, and related
videos, and everything else--
and again, I'm getting way
ahead of myself here, but it's
really interesting to think
that instead of all these
disparate social networks
where YouTube videos may be
shared in different ways, that
you could have a sort of a
central one-stop shopping
where both the video and
the commentary about it
will be in one place.
HANNAH EAVES: I think there
are also some exciting
potential opportunities around
topic tagging, tying into
Facebook's tagging system.
We do that.
Rob would be-- our developer
would be better to talk to
that a little bit.
But there will be, potentially,
the opportunity
down the line to--
Right now, if you like something
on a website you can
see if your friends like
the same article.
There is the potential--
we were looking at a video
about Rupert Murdoch.
You might be able to see other
of your friends liked other
articles, videos and other kinds
of content around that
news story instead of
just this page.
So I think there is an
opportunity eventually for
facilitated conversations, not
facilitated actually, just
organic conversations, on pages
that are about certain
topics, like videos about
certain topics.
BERT HERMAN: Adding to what
David said, I hope we have an
API Meetup up about the Google
Plus API when one exists for
external consumption.
Anyway, one last question.
Right there.
AUDIENCE: Are there any plans
to do any kind of live
curation, live video feeds?
[INAUDIBLE]
BERT HERMAN: The question about
live video curation.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I can
take that question.
So we do have a early version
of our live streaming APIs.
So if you're interested in
them-- in fact, that was one
of my slides, but I only
got five minutes
and I ran over time.
And so we do have two sets of
APIs that we are working on
with partners on integrating.
One is on the discovery front,
on the consumption front.
You can actually discover what
other live events that are
scheduled, when will they be
airing, and what's the URL to
actually consume it?
And then on the other side, we
have APIs that allow a content
owner or a live video producer
to actually hook up with our
system to actually schedule
the event and then
and deliver the event.
So these are very early API's
We are just actively working
on ironing out the kinks out
of it, but if you're
interested in them please chat
with us because we are
actively looking for feedback.
XAVIER DAMMAN: And so if you're
a hacker and you want
to play with this kind of API
we also have a write API.
So you could actually use the
news trimming API of YouTube,
and use that and then turn
that into stories.
So definitely, we want to be a
video system that can plug
into different APIs as a source,
but also as an output.
So there's definitely a lot of
things that can be done there.
And definitely integrating more
wait time is definitely
something that has been
requested a lot.
And that's definitely a thing
that we want to work on.
HANNAH EAVES: We also have done
a lot of live streaming
events with dialogue and
conversation with guests
around the live streaming, we
just haven't done those on the
news website yet.
But I think it's definitely an
interesting idea thought that
we're going to be looking at.
DAVID CLINCH: Just one last
thing because we're all
talking here.
But the political season will
be a really interesting
experiment area for that.
We're definitely discussing with
our partners, YouTube and
others, the idea that you could
do live curation of
content around live political
events and things like that
would be really interesting.
We'd love to see more
YouTube live news.
It's very frustrating to us when
there are YouTube videos
and then there is live video
from another source.
We'd love that live
video to be on
YouTube as much as possible.
BERT HERMAN: OK.
Well yeah, I think we're
going to wrap up here
as far as the questions.
I do, definitely, before ending
here, really do want to
thank very much Hannah and
Link TV, who did help put
together all this and
pay for the drinks.
So part of the reason for this
event tonight is that they've
also released a new report on
youth and video consumption.
Maybe she could quickly mention
that because there's
copies of it here.
HANNAH EAVES: I'd to mention
that because especially some
people who worked on the
report are here.
Andrea Sevari, who did the
research, Lauren House, I'm
not sure she's still here,
our youth division
worked a lot on this.
We did a lot of research with
16- to 25-year-olds about
their news media consumption
habits, with support from the
Knight Foundation, that
we used when thinking
about this news site.
And those findings, a national
survey and several focus
groups, are in the white paper
that was being distributed.
I think there's a lot of really
useful information in
there for people who
are trying to
reach that age group.
BERT HERMAN: So thank
you again.
Thank you, everybody.
Again, if you have questions,
I'm sure everybody's going to
be hanging out up here, and look
forward to seeing at the
next event.
Thanks.